Allah is going to save the Muslims from
Hell by giving them a Jew or a Christian
to replace them what can I have thatone
please shocked
[Music]
shocked now God had to die now can I
explain it now with
ke Ezekiel
1663 what that is so strange I don't I
think that that to me it's kind of
satanic that God had to send a man to
die for man like
satanic can I answer you can think
whatever bis now I'm going to show you
why the Christian position is logical
yours is not can I explain now just
listen and then you can argue with me
but let me finish the
point Muslim why God yes we'll get to
that one why God had to be the one to
make it to me he says I I right yeah I
I'm going to talk how do you do it now
let me show you logic why our Bible is
miraculous it's from God it's beautiful
Christians watch the Beauty and the
wisdom of our God if you have one
sinless man let's say I'm
sinless and I say God I will die in his
place The Sinner so he can be forgiven
the problem
is human life is equivalent to human
life eye for Eye Soul for soul meaning
if I'm a man who's sinless I can only
die for the payment of one man I can't
die for every man because I am not more
valuable than all human lives the only
one who has value a value and worth that
is greater than all mankind combined is
God not even an
angel is equivalent to a human life
because according to the Bible humans
are higher than angels and animals so an
angel can't come and offer his life to
to pay the debt of all humans because an
angel his value is less than a human the
only being whose value is greater than
human you and all creation is God so God
says all right in my love I want to pay
the debt of all human beings who will
turn to me and believe but now you have
another
problem the Deb is human death because
God says if a human sins he dies so a
human death has to occur but God is not
a man God is spirit so what does God do
I will not be
command and die a human death because
when I God die a human death that makes
the death infinite in its
value so now my human death because I'm
God not a human person I'm God who now
becomes human and dies a human death
that makes My Sacrifice of infinite
value and I can cover the debt of all
humans and all creation this is why the
gospel is beautiful and you don't have
it um I I do not think that God need
like I don't think human sacrifices is
needed to cure sins like you can just
ask for forgiveness and God will forgive
you that's that's not true now now can
we show her that's not true B goad he's
gonna show you Allah doesn't simply
forgive you he he de he
demands
kafar atonement I think you guys have
complicated your religion you guys have
comp we complicated it yes because that
is uh very complicated so let me ask you
do you believe that it is satanic it's a
satanic idea that somebody else takes on
the sins of someone else you believe
that that's satanic and evil no no man
could pay for another man's sin and no
beautiful no no man nobody everybody's
accountable for their own sin there no
such thing as if my sister said I'm
accountable for it there's not such
thing as that everyone is accountable
for their own sin and on the day of
judgment God is going to judge that
individual person based on their own
sense and it has always been like that
from the beginning so that doesn't
answer my question do you believe that
it is evil for someone to take on the
sins of another for God to put somebody
else's sins on another person do you
believe that that's
evil it's not it's not it's not even
evil it's just it's illogical it's it's
illogical and so this is something that
all this is something that God would
never
do why would why would somebody commit a
sin and he would put it on somebody else
I'm just I'm just asking you you're
saying God would never do that because
it's illogical it doesn't make
sense he would not give somebody else
somebody else's sin okay so you just
condemned Allah no wait wait before you
go on guys he said she said he will not
condemn you because of someone else's
sins she said it heard it now watch
bis watch what's he's gonna give you
Muslim what are you gonna show s Muslim
2767 a Muslim 2767
a s Muslim 2767 a it says Allah's
messenger said when it will be the day
of Resurrection Allah would deliver to
every Muslim a Jew or a
Christian and say that is your Ransom
from Hellfire that's your rescue from
Hellfire so according to Muhammad Allah
is going to save the Muslims from Hell
by giving them a Jew or a Christian to
replace them what can I have that Hadi
shocked shocked absolutely you can
yeah give me that I I I would have to do
my research my extensive research and I
had it and see what it actually means
that's now it has to mean
something this is why we told you what's
the name of the Muslim so I'm G tell you
where to find it when you go to sun.com
you
listening yeah when you go to sun.com
put in
a 27
672 67a if you're in the comment section
on YouTube we can give you links or if
you Skype me or him now I'm telling you
guys now ain't no way in my Quran and
Allah says that people would piay people
that's what it says
here that I have to see theth and I have
to understand what it actually means you
know let me let me do this for you you
know just for you if we could you links
I'm G flip the screen so you can see it
yourself show her the others to because
we love you and you're our favorite now
watch here all
right you say that be careful don't fall
love with the Christian man you got to
marry Muslim man so look you see it
sahim Muslim 2767 a you see it yeah all
right so it
says Abu musa's report reported that
Allah's messenger
said when it will be the day of
Resurrection Allah would deliver to
every Muslim a Jew or a Christian and
say that is your rescue from
Hellfire isn't that crazy you want show
you want to it gets worse that's not so
did you register
that you got that yeah I'm try I'm
typing it up so I can see the what what
what the verse come out from and what
it's right here it's it's
s
it has to has a reason and mean yeah the
reason is this the reason I don't think
Allah he's gonna give oh yeah there's a
reason there is a reason that's not what
it's saying the reason is the re the
reason is because a Muslim dies
saying right while the Jews and the
Christians are considered as
disbelievers since they reject Allah and
Muhammad so because of that the Muslim
will be rescued from Hell by Allah place
ing their sins upon a Jew or a Christian
why do you say that he's placing our sin
I got you that's all you had to ask I
got you you didn't that's all you had to
ask watch this here's another one Abu
BDA reported on on the authority of his
father that Allah's Apostle said this no
muslim would
die but Allah would admit in his
stead a Jew or a Christian in Hellfire
so Allah's replacing the Muslim with a
Jew or a Christian so the Muslim
deserves to go to hell right but Allah's
going to replace them with a Jew or a
Christian just picture the other one's
gonna show there's another one now watch
this one because you you said ask about
the sins right watch the sins here 6668
so same thing
2767d just remember this is not
Quran I have to see how how strong this
is and how we and what who was saying I
have to say who was saying this why why
did they say this what Muhammad said it
this Muhammad Muhammad said it I would I
I have to do my to see if this is a
authentic Hadith it is it's it's sah
Muslim if it's weak or if it's thing or
what does it Sis Sis it's sah what does
sah
mean
what does sah mean tell
me that's a that's a person sah Muslim
yeah yeah well Muslim is the person what
does sahi
mean I don't know sh s sah means
authentic you have sah which is strong
authentic you have Hassan which is good
you have daif which is weak this is sah
Muslim just like sah alkari
this is sah
Muslim and I'm going to show in the
Quran I'm going to show in the Quran
where it says that you
will
suffer and cause people suffer for your
sins people do suffer because of other
people s show you
that read this y so look s Muslim
2767d don't don't let nobody try to tell
you that it's
weak it says here there would come
people amongst the Muslims on the day of
Resurrection with as heavy sins as a
mountain you w you looking at this I see
I a scre so good so they come the
Muslims will come on the day of
Resurrection with as heavy sins as a
mountain that's how much sins they have
and Allah would forgive them and he
would place in their stead the Jew Jews
and the Christians that's how Allah
forgives them by replacing them with
Jews and Christians taking their sins
that are as heavy as a mountain and
replacing them and placing them on the
Jews and the
Christians okay let me see okay so I
have found the
explanation okay can I show you some
Quran
verses about what about that you suffer
because of someone else's sins
I'm I'm afraid I don't have the
knowledge on this okay but I'll give you
the verses for you to examine I'm just
going to read them for you
right um no it's up to you because you
said Quran he gave you Hadith I want to
give you
Quran yes
no yeah okay here I'm GNA read for you
292 Quran 29 Surah 29 12-13 pay
attention okay want to read it for you
ready you ready yeah okay chapter 29
12-13 write it and those who disbelieve
say to those who believe disbelievers
say to those who believe follow our way
and we will verely bear your
sins never will they bear anything of
their sins surely they are liars now
watch though and verily they shall bear
their own loads and other loads besides
their own and verely they shall be
questioned on the day of Resurrection
about that which they used to fabricate
let me repeat that part they will bear
their own burdens loads of sin and other
loads besides their own so here it's
saying there'll be people who carry
their own loads of sin and the loads of
sins of others why is that it's from an
article on our website now let me give
you another one you ready I have the I
have the meaning for the first verse
that you posted about sah Muslim no you
don't because you Google it's not gonna
help you okay I can I can give the
expanation to you right now if who want
to hear it go try but it's not you know
I have to ask to
speak I know you know have to ask to
speak and and give you can try I gave
you Chron did you pay attention to the
chronic verse I gave you or no um I was
busy
reading okay the Quran just said
29213 here it is it says they will carry
their own burdens and the burdens of
others their sins so here it says there
will be people who carry their own
burden of sins and also the burden of
sins of others why why are they carrying
two loans theirs and someone
else's I I don't know okay can I give
you another one from the
Quran for the Christians for the
Christians that was chapter 29 12-13 are
you ready for the other one or no from
what I know like if I have encouraged
somebody to sin or I taught them
something that was sinful each time they
do it I will get punet as well that's
what I know but I don't think she say
she's saying that for what she knows is
that it's if she teaches to do something
bad she'll be punished for teaching
someone to do something bad so that
means hold on if you cause someone to
sin you share in their
sin meaning that if I teach oh so you do
suffer because of someone's sins if you
have an influence over that if I'm I'm
saying listen to what I'm saying I'm not
saying that if somebody sins it's not my
responsibility but iau them if I had
taught them that sin okay so you taught
someone a sin but they commit sin not
you but you still suffer for the sin
they committed not you yes and also here
here's the next p here's the next p if
if I teach someone good and they have
and
I and they do something good I always or
if you teach someone to do good and he
doesn't good it benefits you yes so when
Jesus did good it benefited you oh my
God I'm not talking about Jesus yes
Jesus is your god oh my god and Lord
savior guys did you hear it wait if I
teach someone to do good and he does the
good y then I will be blessed by the
good he did by the good so Jesus did
good for us and we benefit and we wow
you why are you incorporating Jesus my
beloved prophet in this okay so thank
you for proving the Christian Gospel I
can't even read the other Quran do you
want Quran or you just want to keep
talking I want to give you another Quran
verse my beloved Jesus can I give you
another chronic verse my poor my poor
beloved
Jesus can I give you another chronic I
she goes my poor beloved Jesus because
we we had nailed on the cross you guys
have made my my my peret a lot okay can
I give you another chronic verse on that
we will suffer the sins we committed in
the sins of others yes or no you want it
or no go ahead okay chapter 16 guys
write it down chapter 16 22 to 2 16 22
to 25 okay here you said no it's not yes
it is okay your God is one God so as for
those who do not believe in the
yearafter their hearts are ignorant and
they are proud truly Allah knows what
they hide and what they manifest surely
he does not love the proud and when it
is said to them what is it that your
lord has revealed they say stories of
the Ancients these are fables mom is
reciting that they now watch that they
may bear their burdens entirely on the
day of resurrection and also of the
burdens of Those whom they let as stray
without knowledge now surely evil is
what they bear so you're right if I
mislead him and he sins he gets punished
and I get punished for the sin he
commits but didn't you say no a man
cannot because if someone if I did not
teach or influence anyone to sin and he
come to sin on his own without me even
knowing anything then how am I supposed
to pay for that okay but that wasn't the
point the point was you said another man
cannot bear the sins of someone else you
just change your position you said no no
no no if I teach him to sin and he sins
now he committed to sin canot die for
sin let me finish your point hey brother
why don't you do this man let's get high
I teach him to get high now he goes and
starts getting high every time he gets
high because I taught him I will get
punished for every time he got high
because I taught it to him so that means
I am suffering because of someone else's
sins okay
anyway and can I ask you a final
question I know what I'm speaking about
and the people in the comments they know
what I'm speaking about now by the way
I'm not
it is late he's getting tired not that
he won't get you off he'll bring you
back he is getting tired but I'm going
to ask you one question Adam and Eve
they were in Jenna right yes they were
in Jenna
right Adam and Eve was in yes in Jenna
Jenna that's in heaven
right yes okay so their sin is why they
were thrown to the Earth
right yes they were because dis so they
were in Jenna and they were thrown to
the Earth right uh-huh as punishment
right it was as a punishment yes so why
are you on
Earth I am on Earth because my my
ancestors Adam and Eve are on earth did
you guys hear it clip it archive I'm on
Earth because of Adam and Eve what they
did but I thought you are not to be
punished for someone else's
sin well we came from Adam and Eve we
were born so they got you thrown out of
Jenna so their sin you suffer you can't
say that he can't say yes I can I'm on
Earth Allah will it for us he will it oh
that's what Adam said Adam said Allah
predestined I would sin and get all of
you thrown out of paradise so you can
all be miserable so blame Allah for
making Adam sin so that all of us are
thrown out of J are miserable on Earth
Allah has in the Quran that this world
is a test for us okay is it is a test
have to go through life as by the way
yes when were Adam and Eve
naked well it doesn't say yeah chapter
seven if you read it says that their
clothes was removed so it has it must
have been that they were if you read
chapter 7 of the Quran you start from 19
on it says Allah gave them rment
clothing because of their sin and that's
why the children of Adam were clothes so
you know why you're not naked no no no
that's not what it says it says that
when they send their clothes was move
and when they Clos was remov they hid
behind bushes because they were ashamed
of themselves and they were why were
they what and after that what did Allah
do they were naked so they after that
what did Allah
do I don't know I don't know he he says
in chapter
seven he clothed them and that's why you
children of Adam have clothing in other
words you wear clothes because Adam and
Eve sin and now because of listen you
have to wear
clothes I I listen that's why you're not
naked what you're saying there is not
making any sense because
Allah that whenever a person we're going
to read chapter 7 because this man's got
to sleep he's somebody their clothes
they become more naked so being clothed
is not Is Not a Bad Thing Allah wants us
to cover up
ourselves okay so that we have okay now
here we're going to read now you ready
chapter 7 we're going to read you ready
and Adam settle down in the paradise you
and your wife we're reading chapter 17
from 19 guys listen chapter 17 eat
whatever you wish yet do not approach
the Stree lest you should become
wrongdoers we're going to go go down
slowly so Satan whispered to them to
show them both their private parts which
had gone unnoticed by either of them so
they didn't know they had private parts
okay right he said your lord only
forbids you this tree so that you will
not become two angels or lest you both
become immortal he swore to them I am a
sincere counselor with both of you he
led them on by deceiving them once they
had tasted the tree their private parts
became apparent to both of them it
didn't say they were clothed see this
why I wanted to let you keep talking it
said they were not aware they were not
aware that they had private parts but
when he told them hey you got private
parts she's got private private parts
they ate then became aware oh yeah we
got private parts they got
embarrassed once they had tasted the
tree their private PRS became apparent
to both of them and they started to
patch together leaves from the paradise
for themselves their lord called out to
them did I not forbid you that tree and
tell you both that Satan is an open
enemy of yours they said our Lord we
have harmed ourselves if you do not
forgive us and grant us Mercy we will
will be losers now watch he said clear
out you will become one another's
enemies yet you may have a residence on
Earth and enjoyment for a while so guys
notice the reason why we're on Earth
because Adam and Eve got us thrown out
now why do we wear clothes children of
Adam we have sent down clothing with
which to conceal your private parts and
to dress up in yet the clothing of
heedfulness is V this is one of Allah's
signs so that they may bear it in mind
so bis we just read it they were naked
but they didn't know they had private
parts when they realize they had private
parts that's why Allah then clothe them
and now I have to wear clothes and hide
my love handles because of
Adam thank you Adam I can't show my love
I want to ask you guys a question um do
you guys do you guys support Israel
because it says like people supposed to
support Isel in the Bible and stuff I
let me answer that quickly I am Pro
Jesus Pro Kingdom of Jesus and I condemn
all terrorists all murderers I'm not pro
or anti-israel proanti Palestine
whatever is wrong is wrong my devotion
is to Jesus okay my cousin said that
Israel is the apple of God's eye and
that they are his don't change the
subject stuck for
all the apple of God's eye are those who
belong to Jesus he's true Israel now bis
come back he's tired you change the
subject now he's tired we'll talk okay
we'll talk more good night take care we
like you bis you didn't make me happy
again especially when I saw you wearing
hijab with glasses so you are a
hijabi now that's why you wear clothes
you can thank Adam and Eve that you
don't run around naked but Mar clo being
being covered is a good thing it
protects you and people the men they
lower the gay they respect you more you
respect yourself more so then why does
Islam allow women to be beaten M that's
not true okay we'll talk about come back
tomorrow
backrow he's tired sister he needs
beauty sleep we love you for the sake of
Jesus may you come to Christ come back
tomorrow we'll talk
about Allah bless you guys Jesus blessed
You by bringing you to his glorious
truth who loves you and died for you in
Jesus
name oh my
godic
a